[Music]
identity and access management or iam in
google cloud gives you fine-grained
control over the permissions that users
have today we're going to look at group
membership and the resource hierarchy to
understand how you can allow users to
access resources
let's start on the iam page where we can
see the permissions for different users
on a project in our project the user
user at tsc.junix.com
has the storage object viewer role this
role allows a user to list and download
objects from storage buckets but does
not allow them to create or delete any
objects this role is granted to the user
in the project's iam policy so it will
apply to the whole project in all
buckets in the project
let's take a look at those buckets by
going to the cloud storage page we'll
also open up the cloud shell to run
commands as this user
by running gsutil ls we can list the
items in the specified bucket
when we try to delete an object by using
gsutil rm the command fails with an
error message because we don't have the
storage.objects.delete permission being
able to list the objects but not delete
them is consistent with having the
storage object viewer roll
[Music]
let's take a look at the other bucket in
this project my underscore bucket
underscore 321
we can list the objects in this bucket
in the same way however when we try to
delete an object we can see that the
command is actually successful
what would cause this difference in
behavior between the two buckets since
both buckets belong to the same project
our user should have the same view only
permissions and shouldn't have been able
to delete that object
to investigate this kind of issue let's
use the iam policy troubleshooter here
you can see more details on why a user
or service account does or does not have
a permission we can put in our user's
email the full resource path to the
bucket and the
storage.objects.delete permission we
want to investigate
to see what format to use for full
resource names check the documentation
the policy troubleshooter shows us that
the user does indeed have permissions to
delete objects rather than having that
permission at the project level the
permission is actually at the bucket
level from the storage object admin role
the permissions from this role allow
users to do things like create and
delete objects in addition to viewing
them having this permission at the
bucket level lets this user delete
objects for that specific bucket even
though they can't delete objects for
other buckets in the same project
we can check the binding details to see
that the reason our user has access is
because they belong to a group that has
the storage object admin role on the
bucket
when using the policy troubleshooter you
may need additional permissions to be
able to see the members of a group
you can read more about the policy
troubleshooter in the documentation and
try it out for yourself in the google
cloud console
[Music]